hey guys it's justine and today we're
going to be talking about my favorite
ipad os 15 features i do have the public
beta now running on my ipad and i've
been using it for a little while now so
i'm looking forward to showing you guys
some of my favorite things that i've
been loving about
ipad os 15 but i also have another
little exciting gadget here this
is the logitech combo touch keyboard
there's a lot of cool features in this
that will assist you in turning your
ipad into so much more than an ipad so
huge thank you to logitech for sending
me this to check out and for sponsoring
this video
let's unbox oh look at
this this is actually very light
also very light so the thing that i love
so much about this already is the fact
that it does have a detachable keyboard
so you're able
to just use this as a case and you can
take the keyboard off if you don't want
to use this
cool so one of the things that i already
like about this a lot is it has
these outer protective edges because on
some of the other keyboards that i've
used previously
they don't protect the edge of your ipad
and i
am i don't want to say reckless but i'm
pretty reckless
with my things sometimes so this is
going to be nice to protect
all the way around the edge it does use
the smart connector
so you won't have to actually charge
this keyboard the
keyboard will automatically be charged
through the power
of your ipad
this is very nice i really like
the fabric kind of feel it's like
fabric-y but not
really fabric-y if that makes any sense
i really like the look of this and i do
like that they left
a cutout here up at the top for your
apple pencil
this has a little kickstand it's also
adjustable
this is saying that the combo touch uses
an app you do not have installed yes i
would like to get the app please
the keyboard is up to date allow the
keyboard
is a very nice type i like that this has
a full row of function shortcut keys up
here on the top so you can do things
like adjust the brightness
you can search you can adjust your
keyboard brightness and you can
control your content you can also turn
your volume up and down
and you can even lock your ipad right
there
so this has four different modes there's
a type sketch
read and view mode
[Music]
also take a look at this trackpad this
is like a big trackpad i don't have to
be anywhere specific
it's just full click look at this i'm
clicking all around town
another thing that i'm noticing that i
really like is when i'm scrolling here
on the ipad and i'm actually using the
touchscreen there's not a lot of bounce
so this kickstand is pretty sturdy
that's nice look no bounce writing test
i will put a link in the description if
you guys want to get more information
about it
but so far i'm very impressed look how
nice everything just folds up it's super
compact
it's thin it's light and
it will protect your ipad all the way
around
i think the biggest thing for me even
during the pandemic was when i started
using this
basically as a computer like the ipad is
so incredibly powerful and now with ios
there's a lot of really cool features
that will help you utilize this to
your full potential to its full
potential but for now
let's talk about some of my favorite
features in ipad os 15.
the first feature that i'm such a huge
fan of is the way they've made
the multitasking so much easier on here
with split view i've got this little
button up here
now these little three dots that you can
click that can automatically turn this
into your main full screen but you can
go
to these various types of split screen
so over here i have just the newsroom
article talking about ipad os 15 and
over here
i have my book in the books app
i can make this one smaller and it's
nice because this is kind of like a
little floating window
and then the one behind it is the full
screen so you can kind of just
figure out very quickly like what you
want to have multitasking i think that i
might want
to multitask with um
i don't know apple tv did you guys watch
home before dark it was an incredible
show i absolutely loved it so when you
have these things in split view and you
go into
sort of like your little app switcher
it's cool because
that multi-view with apple tv and safari
actually will stay put so you won't lose
what you're working on
in the multitasking split view this now
has some widgets that you're able to add
which is really nice
i'm going to add let's see what kind of
widget
will i like to add maybe i'll add some
stocks
do i want to have it be a big big boy
i'm gonna have a look at that look at
that big freaking stock that i've just
added to my home screen
completely unnecessary the quick notes
feature
absolutely love this swipe up from the
right i can
start a note i can just quickly do some
writing
i can change my colors and something
else that's really new and cool in the
notes
is you're able to add hashtags you're
able to tag people so you'll be able to
notify them
when you make a change and we use notes
for everything hello this is
my note title i like notes
they are fun fun hashtag
notes so with hashtags and things like
that it's going to make it easy to be
searchable and be able to organize your
notes better i also love that they have
a feature where you can tag someone
so if i'm working on a script or a
document with my sister
or tyler i can just tag him in the note
and that will push a notification to
tyler to let him know that i tagged him
in a note there's also new emojis
so there's some new emoji settings
there's obviously some new hairstyles
there's some new headwear and a bunch of
different accessories
and there's also clothing i can choose
the colors
that's hideous let's do a white i'm
gonna make this one also pink
but maybe like a light light pink that's
nice
and you can pick from some new kind of
like
half body emoji
expressions facetime has got an update
so you're able to do
grid view if you have multiple people
and doing multiple calls there's also
something that's really awesome is you
can now
share a link and if somebody doesn't
have an
apple device or they're on their pc or
they're on a computer they can use that
link to join your facetime call you can
also schedule facetime calls ahead of
time
there's new spatial audio and there's
even voice isolation so it'll be able to
remove all the ambient background sounds
and just focus on your voice but there
is another wide spectrum option so if
you do turn that on
you'll be able to hear everything your
voice and the ambient sounds share play
is a really fun feature i know a lot of
people like to watch content together
but they might not be able to physically
be together so with share play you're
able to kind of hop on facetime
it'll sync the video and the audio so
you guys will be able to enjoy this
viewing experience all together i love
the new shared with you feature so if
you have kind of like a group i message
going on or just texting friends back
and forth with a bunch of different
content and photos this will
automatically go into your photo library
if
you choose so you won't have to go and
save
every single image individually this
will also work with apps and music and
news stories so anything that was shared
with you
will now have its new home focus is
pretty cool so if you turn
focus on there's a few different options
that you can choose from and each one of
these
things you can set to do different
things so if i'm driving
i obviously don't want to have any
notifications popping up i don't want to
be
getting distracted when you have focus
on you can have the option to let people
know that you have this feature on so
that they'll know that that's why you're
not responding you have do not disturb
on
you have your focus you are focused and
you'll get back to them
when you turn it off i'm just gonna like
permanently keep the sleeping
focus feature on forever the
notifications have
also been redone safari has a big update
as well i like the new safari tabs right
up here
it just kind of gives you more space to
scroll and the
you'll notice that the little address
bar disappears
they've added some really cool
enhancements into the photos app there's
live text so you're able to
live search text that is in photos with
using ai to recognize all of the text
in these photos but this is also kind of
cool there's a visual look up
so this will show you information about
your photos so i'm going to click on
this little doggie this is rosanna's dog
blueberry and it will look up
personalized suggestions from the web
itunes the app store and let's see what
it has to say
about blueberry it said it's a french
bulldog
yeah this is cool they've also updated
the interactive memories which is such a
fun little thing like they make like
little videos
and kind of compile them all together so
they're giving you more customization
features in that which is kind of neat
and last but not least one of my
favorite features is universal control
and i can't actually show you this here
now because i don't have a computer
running the beta of mac os monterey
but when everything is running together
i can turn my ipad
my macbook and my imac all into kind of
one working machine
i guess it's kind of magic because i can
have my ipad sitting to the left my imac
would be here
and my macbook would be here and i can
just use
one keyboard one mouse which is really
incredible especially if you don't have
multiple monitors but you do have
multiple
devices these can basically act as
external monitors but they're not
actually monitors
i cannot wait to try this out well thank
you guys for watching i hope you enjoyed
this look at some of my favorite ipad os
15 features i'd love to hear from you
guys
is there anything that you're looking
forward to in this latest release
of ipad os or ios 15 or
apple watch or mac os monterey
i'd love to hear it i'll see you guys in
the comments below
[Music]
you